chili beef lettuce wraps cooking should
never be a chore
the more you cook the more confident you
become that way
you actually start to enjoy it and
that's the key to good cooking
have a bit of fun along the way
this is minced beef and minced pork the
pork
needs to sit in there otherwise the
beef's gonna dry out it's really
important to season the mince before you
cook it
pan nice and hot a touch of olive oil
mince in breaking up like that really
helps to sort of
separate it so we can fry it off with a
lot of color
with your spoon just go through
i'll start breaking that up the most
important thing to remember
is mint is made up of cheap cuts brisket
belly
short rib so it needs help and frying
off the mince for color it's so
important
if this pan wasn't hot your mince is
gonna boil
it's a horrible gray color on there and
there's no flavor on your mince
taste a little bit
tastes delicious it's seasoned beefly
see how crispy it's going
take it much further than you ever taken
mince before
nice and crispy smells incredible
i'm draining it it's crucial it keeps
the mints nice and crispy
and you get rid of that excess fat
that's lovely now just wipe out the pan
then wash it
low gas now we're going to add texture
to the mince
finely chopped chili ginger
garlic and spring onions spring onions
give this sort of
mince a really nice freshness because it
just gives that crunch
nice and thinly now i'm gonna fry off
the chilis the ginger the garlic first
sesame seed oil teaspoon only in
garlic chili ginger in
fry that off nicely the sesame seed oil
just
lifts up the whole flavor brown sugar
that starts to really caramelize the
chili the garlic
and the ginger mince in
[Music]
now my fish sauce that gives it the
saltiness
can see now why it's so important to get
that mince really crispy because
nothing's going soggy staying really
crispy
fresh lime that makes the mince fragrant
and then lime juice roll it
and squeeze that in there incredible
i've got the salty i've got the heat
i've got the sweetness now i've got the
acidicness as well and then finally
my spring onions in right at the last
minute so i've got crunch in there as
well
smells amazing literally cook the mince
now with
sort of 30 seconds to go
gas off and take it out
looks incredible smells so inviting
to go with the chili beef i'm making a
simple sweet and spicy dipping sauce
so everyone can dress the crispy mince
to their own taste
dipping sauce a little teaspoon the
brown sugar
soy sauce gives it a nice sort of dark
rich color
sesame seed oil a tablespoon and just
top that up with a tablespoon
of olive oil that stops the sesame seed
all becoming
too rich a teaspoon of fish sauce
and then a touch of chili leave the
seeds in again
i want the heat in that sauce
[Music]
so impressive an amazing show off
centerpiece lime juice in
in the coriander chop it through once
give that little mix up just check the
seasoning
[Music]
that's lovely nice and rich now the
lettuce
i'm going to use baby gem because it's
really nice and durable and sort of
quite strong
so you just sort of sit these nice
trimmed lettuce leaves around
now the exciting part to serve take your
lettuce up
spoon in your mince and then
a little touch of dressing just a little
drizzle
nice and that's the secret of having
good easy relaxed food is that
you just help yourself food that looks
and tastes a million bucks
doesn't have to be complex this dish is
as fun to cook
as it is to eat
[Music]
green papaya salad this is a great salad
to serve at a party it's delicious and
robust enough to last the whole evening
without wilting
first off these are a little dried
shrimp
you can buy them anywhere they smell
almost sort of
the sea bed into the pestilence for this
salad inspired by my travels across
thailand i'm starting by making a
wonderfully spicy paste
a little salt in there in
just break them up this paste is like a
staple ingredient in thailand
that's what we're looking for almost
it's like a powder
right next just one clove of garlic
[Music]
slice up the garlic and get that
into the pest and water bird's eye chili
incredibly hot
powerful but wow it does give an amazing
kick to the paste
[Music]
in to the mix now
a couple of tablespoons of brown caster
sugar
that softens the blow with a chili and
then just to get that nice sour taste
a little bit of hot water into this
tamarind paste
it's really tart but sweet paste one
tablespoon in
fish sauce now it's got that almost sort
of pickly
smell slightly salty but the flavor is
intense
two tablespoons and bring that together
and give it a really good mix
[Music]
some lime juice in half another touch of
tartness so the pace is nice and thick
and fragrant but it's got the heat the
sourness
the tartness incredible
green papaya stand it up give it a
little peel
you can find green papaya and local
asian shops and bigger supermarkets
and as it doesn't wilt like more
delicate veg it's perfect
for robust salads like this i grate it
look that's what i want these
slithers next a nice rich
sweet banana shallot
[Music]
nice some carrot carrot gives it
another texture
[Music]
now niffle that and mix it
finish that off with thai basil and
fresh coriander
thai basil is a much more fragrant
basil it's stronger and it's slightly
thicker as well
like papaya and tamarind paste you can
get thai basil in good supermarkets
and independent asian stores but normal
basil works well too
next prepare the crunchy topping pan on
and toast some peanuts
chop the nuts but it gives a really nice
crunch
in they go roll them around the pan
gas off and just stick them out
now for the exciting part i'm going to
dress the salad
nice spoon of dressing in to the papaya
mix that in
and then finally a nice general
sprinkling
roasted nuts and that is one delicious
very fragrant very robust
green papaya salad so easy to make and
guaranteed
not to go limp a perfect party salad and
with such incredible colors textures and
bold exciting flavors
it's sure to grab your guests attention
red mullet with sweet chilli sauce
cooking is about being adventurous and
having the confidence to go off piste
and
being a little bit more daring so when
you start combining peanuts
chili flakes and this amazing fish red
mullet
trust me you're in for an amazing treat
we're gonna make a really nice light
sweet chili sauce
first off your chili off with the top
in half and those seeds inside
are very powerful incredibly
hot but full of flavor
garlic two cloves of garlic
slice the garlic nice and thin so it
helps to puree
the chilies in the pest and water garlic
in
such a salt a little touch of sugar
in and then start grinding
push down first the salt and the sugar
really helps the puree the chili and the
garlic
fish sauce always a base to a chilli
sauce two tablespoons in
and a touch of rice wine vinegar fish
sauce gives it the saltiness
the vinegar gives it a nice acidic
wake up three tablespoons of olive oil
nice mix that up beautiful look at it
the colors
incredible now spring onions i want the
texture
and the crunch spring onions in the
coriander
slice it once in
fresh lime and that goes brilliantly
with the red mullet
just really wakes up the chili the
garlic
and reminds the sauce that we're serving
it with fish
now taste
[Music]
wow that's delicious look at that
beautiful the longer that chili sauce
sits there
the better it gets now for the peanuts
and chili that's going to coat the top
of the red mullet
peanuts in salt
in that helps to really grind the
peanuts down some beautiful dried chili
flakes
creates a nice sort of warm heat
i'm using fresh chili for the sauce but
dried chili flakes for the coating
which will really crunch up when cooking
just a little bit of coriander
mix the coriander in to the peanuts and
look
i like them quite textured i don't want
them too small as a powder
otherwise they'll burn but crushed
lightly to coat the fish with the chili
and peanut seasoning
in a separate bowl beat two eggs along
with a splash of fish sauce
take your fillet lay in your red mullet
dip it in shake up your peanuts
and then in and make sure you push that
down cover that red mullet
beautiful now make sure that pan's
really nice
and piping hot if you put the fish in
and the pan is cold
all those wonderful peanuts and chilli
just gonna slide off the fish so we need
to sear it in and get it nice and crisp
in and lay away from you beautiful
[Music]
if the pan starts getting a little bit
too hot get your olive oil
and just place another teaspoon of olive
oil around the outside so it starts to
heat up
as it hits the center and it really
helps to stay so much more in control
and turn nice and gently
you want that nice sort of toasted
sauteed
crispness which adds a really lovely
flavor
tilt the pan and just baste
the top of the red mullet with that
really nice piping hot
olive oil you've got that really nice
roasted crunch
and it goes brilliantly with that soft
sweetness of that fish inside
get off and just leave them sitting in
there
and finish with lime and just go over
each one
now we'll take them out
and the sauce touch on the bottom and
the tail of each fish
[Music]
now to round that off serving some
fragrant rice
sauteed broccoli amazing and there you
have
a delicious peanut and crusted red
mullet
with a wonderful sweet chilli sauce
cooking with chilis isn't all about blow
your head off heat
this dish uses the exciting taste of a
chili but has a deliciously elegant
and subtle flavor
you